arriving to support his mother
the prince of wales was driven into the
grounds at windsor castle
as the military carried out their final
preparations
ahead of his father's funeral tomorrow
the irony of covid is that the duke of
edinburgh
who never liked all the panoply and
state wanted
no dramas about his dying and this
is the event that perhaps he would have
most required
it is measured it is tidy it is
disciplined
and it's the best salute the armed
forces could give
30 people will make up the congregation
with the duke's children and
grandchildren
represented in the procession to the
chapel led by the prince of wales
and princess anne the queen will be
accompanied by a lady in waiting as she
is driven behind the coffin
family members will be socially
distanced will wear face masks and the
congregation
won't sing with a seating plan not due
to be released until saturday
it is anticipated the queen may sit
alone
and members of the family will not wear
military uniform
and that's to try and keep the attention
away from those
who've recently stepped away from royal
duties and keep the focus
onto the legacy of prince philip
inevitably though there is going to be
interest
in prince william and prince harry
brought together again to mourn their
grandfather's loss
walking in the same line in the
procession behind his coffin
but separated by their cousin peter
phillips
it's hoped that touches like this will
be a reminder of the man
they'll be remembering this unique mode
of transport
chosen by the duke to carry his coffin
a land rover that he helped design
mike greton worked alongside prince
philip
as the chief executive of the duke of
edinburgh award
and saw for himself the family man that
he could be
we were in buckingham palace and the the
magic hour arrived for the meeting to
start
and he wanted to get on with it but
one member wasn't there and that was his
son prince edward
he was quite grumpy so well let's get on
with this but two minutes later
the door opened and in walked prince
edward
and the first thing you've heard me did
was leak to his feet and kiss him on
both cheeks
now i was caught out by that it was
lovely to see
and not what i expected it just shows
his love for his family and his humanity
on saturday it will become clear just
how much prince philip
was involved in the planning from the
music to military ceremony
making his mark until the very end
rhiannon mills sky news at windsor
castle